grüß Sie ganz herzlich zu unserem
heutigen Pressestatement vor der
Fraktionssitzung dem obligatorischen mit
dem Fraktionsvorsitzenden Dietmar bsch
bitte ja auch von mir einen schönen
guten Tag meine Damen und Herren bevor
ich zu dem Thema was sie vermutlich alle
am meisten interessiert will ich doch
auf einen Punkt inhaltlich verweisen der
aus meiner Sicht zumindest eine gewisse
Weichenstellung vornimmt wir haben ja in
der letzten Woche Meinungsäußerung des
Verteidigungsministers gehabt und
gleichzeitig eine Meldung zur Erhöhung
der Hilfen für die Ukraine ich möchte zu
beidem kurz etwas sagen ich finde das
nicht nur problematisch wenn Boris
Pistorius die Bundeswehr kriegsbereit
und kriegstüchtig machen will ich finde
es auch nicht nur ein verbales Problem
sondern dort steht ja mehr dahinter und
ich finde es gerade auch für einen
Sozialdemokraten ausgesprochen
problematisch denn bisher habe ich von
der SPD immer etwas von
Verteidigungsbereitschaft gehört und
gelesen dass es diesen Wandel gibt das
ist nicht nur eine verbale Frage sondern
da geht es um mehr wir sehen das auch
bei den konkreten Umsetzungen bei dem
Haushalt der demnächst verhandelt werden
wird wo es enorme Steigerung gibt nach
natokriterien über 85,5 Milliarden
erstmalig auch über 2% das alles sehen
wir als LINKE als ausgesprochen
problematisch an und ich will auch den
besonderen Punkt der Verdopplung der
Militärhilfe für die Ukraine benennen
das ist aus meiner Sicht wenn man von 4
auf 8 Milli geht und gleichzeitig bei
der Kindergrundsicherung in Deutschland
nicht annäherend die ursprünglich
geforderten 12 Milliarden von Frau Paus
bereitstellt sondern 2,4 die nicht mal
die gesetzlich verbrieften Leistung
abdecken dann sehe ich das als ein
ausgesprochen großes Problem an und es
sagt etwas über die Prioritätensetzung
der sich selbst so ja ursprünglich
nennenden
fortschrittskoalition ich kritisiere das
in großer Deutlichkeit und ich halte das
für
brandgefährlich bei vielen sozialen
Bereichen in unserem Land ich habe die
Kindergrundsicherung
ähm symbolisch benannt in dieser Art und
Weise zu kürzen und gleichzeitig diese
Erhöhung was die ukrainehilfe betrifft
vorzunehmen ich will Z möchte zumindest
auf die Zahlen verweisen die ja das
Institut der Weltwirtschaft in Kiel zum
31.07 diesen Jahres vorgelegt hat da hat
Deutschland bisher 17 Milliarden
Militärhilfe geleistet Großbritannien 7
Itali sogar 0,7 Milliarden und
Frankreich 0,5 Milliarden ich finde
mindestens mindestens dass das
nachdenkenswerte Zahlen sind und hier so
sehr aus der Hüfte zu sagen es gibt eine
Verdopplung sehe das als sehr
problematisch an und wir werden das auch
in Deutlichkeit kritisieren mein zweiter
Punkt ist der wir haben ja in der
letzten Woche in der Fraktion DIE LINKE
einstimmig beschlossen dass wir heute
die Liquidation der Fraktion beschließen
wollen das war angekündigt und ich gehe
davon aus dass es heute auch beschlossen
wird natürlich ist es ein gravierender
Einschnitt wir haben allerdings damit
dann auch Klarheit dieser sehr sehr
lange auch lebende Prozess ist beendet
in jedem Fall ist dieser Tag kein Grund
zur Freude es kann kein Grund zur Freude
sein denn links von der Ampel wird im
nächsten Jahr keine Fraktion mehr sitzen
es ist eine Niederlage letztlich für
alle Mitglieder meiner Fraktion
natürlich ist auch für mich eine
Niederlage und ich glaube auch dass es
am Ende des Tages Konsequenzen für unser
Land haben wird wenn es keine linke
Fraktion mehr im Deutschen Bundestag
gibt wir verlieren logischerweise
zunächst Rechte und auch Möglichkeiten
um beispielsweise soziale Verbesserung
anzumahen will da an die letzte Woche
erinnern wir haben den Antrag den
Mindestlohn auf 14 € zu erhöhen
eingebracht ich lese von Lars Klingbeil
von Ricarda lang von vielen anderen dass
es dringend notwendig wäre ja es wäre
dringend notwendig so wie Olaf Scholz
als er noch in Hamburg war die 12 €
postuliert hat und durchgesetzt hat als
Kanzler wäre es jetzt aufgrund der
Inflation dringend geboten
auch hier zu agieren das ist nur ein
Beispiel ich könnte Ihnen sehr sehr
viele aufzählen es ist auch klar dass
wir versuchen werden möglichst zügig als
Gruppe hier im Bundestag zu agieren
diese Entscheidung liegt natürlich nicht
bei uns aber damit sind Möglichkeiten
und auch Einfluss wieder deutlich erhöht
eine Gruppe kann politisch viel bewirken
immer deutlich sagen lieber einig mit 28
als zerstritten mit 38 ich will auch in
großer Klarheit sagen dass die Partei
die jetzt noch keinen Namen hat nicht
der Bezugspunkt unserer Politik sein
wird sondern die ampelpolitik hier im
Deutschen Bundestag ist die die wir von
links zu kritisieren haben und eigene
Vorschläge zu unterbreiten haben das
werden wir wenn wir als Gruppe
konstituiert sind auch wieder tun und
ich will betonen dass die Liquidation
das ist so ein Begriff der sich etwas
problematisch anhört ich meine ich war
mal Unternehmensberater da gab es das
hin und wieder das liquidiert wurde
was immer auch eine Chance war ich will
aber vor allen Dingen darauf hinweisen
dass es keinesfalls das Ende der Linken
ist die Linke agiert weiterhin wir
Regieren in drei Bundesländern stellen
einen Ministerpräsidenten in meinem
Bundesland melenburg- vorpomn regiert
erfolgreich eine rotrote Koalition in
meinem Wahlkreis in Rostock stellen wir
als LINKE die Oberbürgermeisterin und so
gibt es viele Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter der Linken die nicht nur
weiter aktiv sein werden die diese
Chance natürlich auch nutzen wollen es
ist eine Chance für einen neustaat diese
Chance gilt es entschlossen wahrzunehmen
aber es gibt eine aus meiner Sicht
existentielle Voraussetzung es muss
Schluss sein mit der wirklich
unsäglichen Selbstbeschäftigung es muss
Schluss sein mit permanent
Auseinandersetzung die Chance ist jetzt
da es gibt auch nicht mehr den
Bezugspunkt auf ja nur eine Person ich
habe das schon am vergangenen Wochenende
erleben dürfen in Sachsen bei einem
Parteitag wo ich wirklich überrascht war
wie entschlossen und wie engagiert die
Mitglieder dort in den Landtagswahlkampf
gehen werden am Ende des Tages wird eine
Zahl sein die wird es eine Zahl geben
die entscheidet ob dann das was ich hier
als Möglichkeit aufgezeigt habe wirklich
eingetreten ist und das wird die Zahl
sein die im September des Jahres 25 bei
der Bundestagswahl aufusleuchtet das ist
das Kriterium wenn wir es schaffen und
das muss das Ziel sein wieder als
Fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag in den
Bundestag einzuziehen dann war es
erfolgreich ansonsten eher nicht dieses
Ziel das ist eine ja eine Herkules
Aufgabe aber wir haben schon andere
Aufgaben bewältigt vielleicht ist auch
diesmal die Möglichkeit dafür da danke
schön Frau Maura sie die erste Frage
muss der oder die Liquidator
liquidatorin mitbringen und wen haben
Sie ein Blick also die Liquidatoren
haben eine Aufgabe die im Wesentlichen
gesetzlich vorgegeben ist
eines ist klar wir werden die
Erfahrungen die es ja im Deutschen
Bundestag gibt die Grünen haben im Jahre
1990 liquidiert die FDP hat unlängst
eine Liquidation durchgeführt und wir
haben als PDS auch schon mal eine
Liquidation durchführen müssen diese
Erfahrung werden wir aufnehmen und das
ist vor allen Dingen die auf gabe
gesetzeskonform zu agieren weil das ja
auch von der Bundestagsverwaltung
entsprechend begleitet wird über die
Personen gebe ich ihn gerne Auskunft
nach der Sitzung weil wir das in wenigen
hoffe Minuten beschließen werden
bitteber mit 28 Leuten in einer Gruppe
geeint handeln als mit 38 zerstritten
sind Sie sich sicher dass diese 28 dann
auch am gleichen Strang ziehen und mit
Blick auf die Zukunft der
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter der
Linksfraktion können Sie ungefähr eine
Größenordnung sagen wie viele dieser
Personen bei einer künftigen Gruppe noch
beschäftigt sein können also was das
erste betrifft kann ich
ja hier nur Wünsche äußern und kann das
sagen wofür ich stehe ich glaube dass es
dringend no notwendig sein wird das
heißt ja überhaupt nicht dass man bei
jeder Frage die gleichen Positionen
haben muss das wäre ja verheerend für
eine linke und ich finde auch dass man
auch inhaltlichen Streit sehr wohl äh
führen kann ich weiß dass Überschriften
äh dann in der Regel heißen Streit bei
der Linken zum Thema y das ist aber
nicht mein Problem solange dieser
kulturvoll und in der Sache ausgetragen
wird habe ich auch nichts gegen ein Maß
an Öffentlichkeit aber jetzt wird es vor
allen Dingen darauf ankommen dass wir
gemeinsam agieren die nächsten Aufgaben
sind übersichtlich wir versuchen
natürlich möglichst zeitnahgruppe zu
werden wir werden versuchen uns
möglichst zeitnah zu organisieren und
konstituieren und dann geht es darum
dass wir unsere politischen Inhalte äh
gerade hier im Deutschen Bundestag mit
Blick auf die Ampel umsetzen und auch
die drei ostdeutschen Landtagswahlen in
den Blick nehmen was die Frage der
Mitarbeiterin und Mitarbeiter betrifft
kann ich Ihnen nur sagen dass diese
Frage offen ist das hängt von vielen
Faktoren ab das entscheiden nicht wir
aber eins kann ich Ihnen gesichert sagen
dass wir natürlich versuchen werden
viele der Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter durch die wir kluge Anfragen
stellen konnten teilweise gute Reden
halten konnten und Einfluss auch hier
auf die Politik nehmen konnten dass wir
die Mitarbeit und Mitarbeiter dringend
brauchen und dass wir möglichst zeitnah
versuchen werden auch Menschen in der
hoffentlich dann neuen Gruppe was auch
nicht wir entscheiden sondern andere
auch
wieder für Engagement und für die Linke
zu begeistern Frau
palser wan wird der S jetzt sein also
derquidationstag erstens und zweitens
sie haben ja gesagt es gibt schon
Erfahrung sie selber haben als PDS
damals Mitglied auch Erfahrung wie lange
dauert das eigentlich bis man sagt ich
möchte eine Gruppe sein dass man dann
auch eine Gruppe wird das muss ja der
Bundestag bestimmen nur so ungefähr also
zum Stichtag sage ich Ihnen direkt nach
der Sitzung werde ich Ihnen den Stichtag
sagen den wir beschlossen beschließen
werden das entscheidet die Fraktion und
ich werde dazu ein Vorschlag
unterbreiten den ich hier vorab nicht
nennen werde
was die Frage der
zeitlichen Abläufe betrifft ist die
erste Frage wann eine Gruppe anerkannt
wird und diese entscheiden nicht wie das
entscheidet der Deutsche Bundestag da
gibt es dann einen entsprechenden
Beschluss dazu den hat es auch im Jahre
94 wo wir auch Gruppe gewesen sind
gegeben da haben wir im Übrigen über das
Verfassungsgericht eine Vielzahl von
Rechten erstreiten können die inzwischen
unstrittig sein werden weil das
verfassungsgerichtsurteile sind die
zeitlichen Abläufe da gibt es viele
Fragezeichen und das wird von konkreten
Dingen abhängig sein ich will das nur
bezüglich der Liquidation mal sagen die
FDP hat 6 Jahre liquidiert wir als PDS
damals waren deutlich schneller aber das
sind offene Fragen und das hängt von
vielen vielen subjektiven Dingen ab eine
Prognose wer da völlig unzulässig und
ähnliches es auch was das Thema Gruppe
betrifft eines kann ich Ihnen allerdings
sagen wir werden alles unternehmen das
es möglichst schnell geschieht und wir
werden mit Sicherheit äh einen
entsprechenden Antrag äh Stellen
mindestens sage ich mal mit dem Tag der
Liquidation Herr
Jahn ähm ich wollte eigentlich ähm die
Kollegin Palzer ist mir etwas
zuvorgekommen nach den zeitlichen
Abläufen sagen das heißt aber sie
streben an die Frist zwischen Ende
Fraktion alle sind
einzelabgeordnete und Anerkennung als
Gruppe möglichst kurz zu machen das gibt
eine gewisse Logik dafür sich zu
engagieren weil man von da an andere
Möglichkeiten hat weil es gibt dann
wieder die Mitgliedschaften in
Ausschüssen es gibt dann wieder die
Möglichkeit von Redezeiten also alles
was parlamentarisch geboten ist das kann
man in den Beschlüssen wo der Bundestag
jeweils für Gruppen festgelegt hat was
deren Rechte sind nachlesen die sind so
klein
nichtfage ja dazu müssen sie ja auch mit
dem Bundestagspräsidium und mit der
Bundestagsverwaltung sich ins Benehmen
setzen ich nehme stark an dass dazu
Gespräche führen können Sie dazu das
bejahen und uns auch sagen sozusagen was
sie da bereden ich kann
selbstverständlich und kann ih
selbstverständlich nicht sagen was ich
da
berede
B Mitarbeiter sind betroffen davon jetzt
wahrscheinlich von Kündigung sobald die
Auflösung beschlossen ist welche Fristen
gibt es da bis wann können Sie wieder
welche einstellen wenn sie als Gruppe
anerkannt werden wie viele ungefähr sind
betroffen und wir können einstellen wenn
ein gruppenanerkenntnis vorliegt und
entsprechende Weisung erfolgt sind weil
es ist ja an die Finanzzuweisung
gebunden wie viele das sein werden das
oblegt dann auch der neuen Gruppe und
deswegen wäre das Vermessen da jetzt
über wirklich konkrete Zahlen zu reden
aber ich habe den politischen Anspruch
genannt den will ich gern wiederholen
natürlich versuchen wir diejenigen die
sehr sehr dringlich gebraucht werden
denen auch vorher zu signalisieren dass
sie gebraucht werden und dass wir sie in
einer neuen Gruppe brauchen denn eines
ist doch ganz klar wenn wir erfolgreich
wiederkommen wollen wenn wir
Unterstützung für die anstehenden
Wahlkämpfe leisten wollen also jetzt ich
sag mal mindestens ehrenamtlich oder
auch durch die Abgeordneten dann sind
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
unendlich wichtig weil Abgeordnete
glauben zwar dass sie wichtig sind und
sind sie ja auch aber ohne Mitarbeiter
sind sie in der Regel gar nichts ja nach
dem Moment wo die Fraktion sich auflöst
fließen keine Mittel mehr das heißt Sie
müssen kündigen
erstmal mit einer Liquidation muss
gekündigt werden Punkt das ist
Gesetzeslage gib's kein Ermessen Herr
Liemann
ja das für sie jetzt heute auch der
Abschied von dieser Stelle oder streben
sie auch an den gruppenvorsitz zu
übernehmen le der Abschied von dieser
Stelle wird es dann nicht sein wenn z.B
in der nächsten Sitzungswoche wir
Fraktion sein sollten dann werden sie
mich und Herrn Schlick hier Wiedersehen
alle anderen Fragen kann ich Ihnen und
will ich ihn auch gar nicht beantworten
weil das wäre wirklich vermessen es wäre
vermessen wir haben eine Situation wo
man eine Entscheidung nach der anderen
treffen kann und nicht etwa über ich
kann auch gern darüber reden wie wir
2029 dann zweistellig in den Bundestag
einziehen BL das ist genauso albern als
wenn ich jetzt über diese Frage reden
würde ja dann sehe ich keine weiteren
frag Frau Schuler bitte sind sie denn
ganz sicher dass die verbliebenen 28
eine Gruppe bilden werden oder könnte es
theoretisch sein dass auch diese Gruppe
sich noch mal aufspaltet bzw haben sie
die Sorge oder Hinweise darauf dass
Abgeordnete vielleicht sich auch anderen
Fraktionen nicht der wagennechtgruppe
sondern anderen Fraktionen und Parteien
anschließen schauen Sie ich kann für
mich eine klare Aussage treffen seit der
Entscheidung des Abgeordneten Thomas
Lutze lege ich keine Hände mehr in Feuer
aber ich kann Ihnen eine klare
Zielstellung sagen und die Zielstellung
ist wir haben einen Auftrag den haben
Wählerinnen und Wähler uns gegeben über
2 Millionen haben uns gewählt und diese
Aufgabe gilt es wahrzunehmen und ich
finde es eher problemat
wenn man für eine Partei in diesem Fall
für die Linke kandidiert da ein Mandat
erhält durch die Linke und dann sagt nö
ich bin jetzt woanders das finde ich
problematisch da wäre die Konsequenz
eigentlich dass man sagt okay ich gebe
das Mandat zurück weil ich ja mit der
Vereinigung mit der Partei nicht mehr
kann aber Sorgen und so weiter wissen
Sie ich habe in den letzten Wochen eine
Vielzahl von nicht nur angenehmen
Entscheidung anderer zur Kenntnis nehmen
dürfen
meine Sorgen halten sich in Grenzen es
ist ganz gut dass ich in Vorpommern
geboren bin und auch weiterhin diese
Mentalität habe und dadurch einige
einigermaßen gute Nerven habe ich hoffe
das hält noch einige Zeit an Frau Wolf
noch mal bitte let
fr bedauern ist dass es keine linke
Kraft mehr links von der Ampel geben
wird würden Sie denn die jetzt den
Verein und die künftige Partei von Frau
Wagenknecht als links von der Ampel
einordnen also ich habe was Sie gesagt
haben nicht gesagt ich habe gesagt gibt
keine linke Fraktion das schon ein
gewaltiger Unterschied denn wir werden
links von der Ampel nicht nur platziert
sondern auch politisch agieren was die
neue Formation betrifft da kann ich mich
schlecht zu äußern denn ich habe die
Bundespressekonferenz zwar gesehen aber
das war in einem so allgemeinen gehalten
ansonsten projizieren sich sie und ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen auf das was
Frau wagenncht sagt das kann interessant
sein aber mich würde mehr interessieren
was dann konkret politik bedeutet ich
höre dass sie regieren wollen noch ist
nicht mal die Partei gegründet noch sind
sie in keinem Parlament sei drum aber da
bleibt der Satz den ich vorhin
formuliert habe die werden nicht der
Bezugspunkt unserer Politik sein sondern
der Bezugspunkt unserer Politik hier im
Bundestag wird die Ampel sein und wir
werden alles tun dass diejenigen die als
nächstes Landtagswahlen haben und das
sind
Brandenburg Sachsen und Thüring dass wir
dort alle Unterstützung geben können und
das heißt natürlich auch dass wir unsere
ostkompetenz wieder schaffen müssen ja
dann sehe ich keine weitere Nachfragen
danke dass Sie zu zahlreich erschienen
sind schönen Tag schöne Woche bis zum
nächsten Mal
haushaltswoche der
haushaltsw